let's find the equation for the
regression line that best fits this
where the fit is the minimizes the
squared distance to each of the points
and then let's actually calculate how
good of a fit it is using an r-squared
we might have to do that in the next
video depending on time so just as a
reminder the line is going to have the
equation y is equal to MX plus B and
we've shown ourselves that the slope of
this line the one that best minimizes
the squared distance to each of those
points is going to be the mean of the X
Y's minus the mean of x times the mean
of Y all of that over the mean of the X
X's squared or the mean of the X
Squared's minus the minus the means of
the X's minus the means of the X's
squared so the way I kind of you know
one way to memorize it I guess is the
first terms kind of have the mean of the
combined things you're multiplying x
times itself first then meaning you're
multiplying x times y times each other
first then meeting and then the second
terms are you finding the means of the
individual components and then
multiplying mean of x times mean of Y
mean of x times mean of X so hopefully
maybe that helps maybe it doesn't but we
can calculate the slope and then the
y-intercept B is just going to be equal
to it's just going to be equal to the
mean of Y mean of Y times whatever we
calculate here for M times the mean of X
and we can do that because we know that
the point mean of X comma mean of Y is
going to be on this regression line so
let's calculate them let's calculate
them and you'll see that we've only the
last example we did three points we only
have four points here but the
computations get more and more intense
so you can imagine what would happen if
you had 10 or 20 or 100 points you
pretty much have to use a calculator at
that point so let's or computer or even
better or a spreadsheet so let's
calculate M and to do that let's
calculate the components so the mean of
X the mean the mean of the X is are
going to be equal to this X is negative
2 negative 2 plus negative 1 plus 1 plus
4 plus 4
all of that over we have four X data
points these two guys cancel out
negative two plus four is two two over
four is equal to one-half now let's do
the mean of the Y's the mean of the Y's
we have negative three negative three we
have a negative one and then we have a
two and then we have a three and once
again we have four data points that guy
and that guy cancel out negative one
plus two is one so this is equal to
one-fourth now let's figure out the mean
of the x wise so the mean so x times y
the mean of that so over here we have
negative two times negative three
negative two times negative three is
positive six positive six plus negative
one times negative 1 is positive 1 plus
1 times 2 is 2 plus 4 times 3 is 12 and
we have four of these points and what is
this this is 6 plus 1 is 7 7 plus 2 is 9
9 plus 12 is 21 over 4 this is equal to
21 21 over 4 do that 7 plus 2 is 9 yep
21 over 4 or you could scripts 14 15 or
up 21 over 4 and then finally we want
this in a new color we want the mean of
the X is squared and so that is going to
be equal to negative 2 squared is
positive 4 plus negative 1 squared is
positive 1 plus 1 squared is 1 plus 4
squared is 16 all of that over 4 if 4
plus 2 is 6 plus 6 is plus 16 is 22 over
4 so 22 over 4 is the same thing as 11
over 2 they do that right 6 plus 16 is
22 over 4
same thing as 11 over 2 so now we're now
ready to calculate the actual slope let
me do it over here well actually let me
do it over here so we're weak I want to
be able to look at everything we've done
I'll do it right over
so this is going to be equal to in this
case it's going to be the mean of the XY
z-- which is 21 over 4 it's 21 over 4
minus the product of the mean of X so
minus so let me do this in a neutral
color minus the mean of X which is 1/2 x
times the mean of the Y's which is 1/4
which is 1 over 4 and then all of that
over the mean of the X Squared's which
is 11 over 2 that is 11 over 2 that's 11
over 2 so we did that - minus the mean
of the X is squared the mean of the X is
once again is 1/2 once again is 1/2 and
so what is this equal to and I'm just
going to do I'm just going to go
straight to the calculator I could deal
with the fractions but this isn't a
review of adding and subtracting and
multiplying fractions so let's just go
straight to the calculator so we get
actually let me simplify it before it's
just too tempting to simplify let me
copy and paste it so let me copy it copy
and then let me paste let's go down here
to calculate it and so this is going to
be maybe I should have used a calculator
but it's too tempting so what's this on
top on top we have 21 over 4 minus 1/2
times 1/4 is minus 1 over 8 all of that
over 11 over 2 minus 1/2 squared which
is 1/4 now one way to simplify this
right from the get-go is multiply the
numerator and the denominator by 8 so
we're going to multiply it by 8 over 8
and that's just to get rid of all of
these fractions so 21 over 4 times 8 is
going to be the same thing as 21 times 2
which is equal to 42 minus 1/8 times 8
we have to of course distribute the
eights so that's going to be minus 1 all
of that over 8 times 11 halves is going
to be 11 times 4 which is 44 and then 8
times 1/4 is 2 so it's minus 2 so 42
minus 1 42 minus 1 is 41 and then 42
minus
or is 42 so the slope is 41 40 seconds
the slope is 41 40 seconds so a little
bit less than a slope of 1 right 40
second 42 40 seconds would be exactly 1
so our regression slope is a little bit
less than 1 and then our regression
y-intercept our regression y-intercept
be V is going to be equal to the mean of
the Y so 1/4 1/4 minus our slope minus
41 over 42 minus 41 over 42 times the
mean of the x's the mean of the X is 1/2
so times so times 1/2 and so this is
going to be equal to 1/4 minus 41 over
80 minus 41 over 84 which is equal to I
could just let me just find a common
denominator so let's go over 84 so
what's 1/4 of 84 1/4 of 80 is 20 so this
is 21 right 21 times 4 is 84 this is 1/4
of 84 my do it yep that's right so it's
going to be 21 minus 41 over 84 which is
equal to negative 20 negative 20 over 84
which is the same thing they're both
divisible by 4 the numerator divisible
by 4 is negative 5 over 21 negative 5
over 21 so our line our regression line
is going to be y is equal to 41 over 42
X minus 5 over 21 and 5 over 21 is a
little bit less than 1/4 right 5 xx
would be 1/4
we made the denominator a little bit
bigger so it's going to be a little bit
less than negative 1/4 so our y
intercept is going to be a little bit
less than negative 1/4 and then we're
going to have a slope a little bit less
than 1 so we're going to go it's going
to our line is going to look something
something like this it's almost it's
going to be a little bit flatter than y
equals x is going to look something like
that if I were able to actually draw
we're able to actually draw a straight
line it would look something something
like that over there so I'm going to
leave you there in this video in the
next video were actually going to
calculate the r-squared for this line
how good of a fit is it how much of the
total variation in the Y values can be
explained by the variation in the X
values or by the line itself